نعود الان لتنظيم داعش في افغانستان
ومناطق وجود التنظيم في افغانستان سنتابع
ونبدا مع التنظيم اين نشا هو نشا في ولايه
ننجرهار ثم بدا يتحرك تدريجيا الى ولايات
الشمال الافغاني وتحديدا في ولايات
بدغشان وتخار وقندوز وبالخ وبغلام
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه تشير الى ان داعش
خرسان ينتشر في هذه الولايات التي تحدثنا
عنها لضعف سيطره طالبان فيها كما ان له
وجود في العاصمه نذكر مشاهدينا هنا ان
حركه طالبان اعلنت قبل اسبوع قتل مسؤولين
التابعين لداعش في كابول خلال الايام
الماضيه احدهما مسؤول اقليمي والاخر قائد
الجناح العسكري اما عن عديد عناصر داعش
خرسان قدرت الامم المتحده اعدادهم بثلاثه
الاف مقاتل فيما تعتقد معاهده الامن
الجامعي انهم سته الاف مقاتل حركه طالبين
بدورها نشرت تقديرات تشير الى ان عدد
عناصر داعش خرسان يصل الى سبعه الاف عنصر
وبشكل عام تعتمد داعش خرسان في تسليحها
على الاسلحه المتوسطه وايضا الخفيفه
هذه التطورات مشاهدينا تاتي بعد يوم من
تحذير رئيس المخابرات الدفاعيه الامريكيه
للجنرال من ان التنظيم القاعده لا يشكل
تهديدا لامريكا في الوقت الحالي مشيرا الى
انه يحاول النجاه الا انه حذر من خطر داعش
في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
تقلصت قدرتنا على معرفه ما يحدث في
افغانستان منذ سقوط الحكومه لكن لا تزال
لدينا بعض القدره على ذلك وبناء على ما
نعرفه بشان تهديد القاعده هم يحاولون
النجاح ولا خطط لديهم للهجوم على الغرب
قريبا يعتقد ان تنظيم داعش هناك يشكل
تهديدا اكبر هم يتعرضون للهجوم من نظام
طالبان الان وهي مساله وقت قبل ان يكون
لديه القدره على مهاجمتنا